I'm sure the dogs knew that events were
happening with the declining health of
her majesty
[Music]
dogs are very perceptive of changes in
their owners in beagles General Health I
mean there's a whole medical charity
devoted to a study of this amazing
ability of dogs to pick up on illness in
people so yeah I'm sure they knew that
the Her Majesty was in Decline and they
would have missed her I doubt there will
be serious changes in Behavior we'll
call it grief because they were so used
to being cared for by other members of
the household and of course by prince
Andrew who was present at the death and
is taking over their care now that was
such a touching image of the two corgis
lined up watching the passing of the
hearse I doubt they realized that that
was a close proximity of Her Majesty's
body in dogs are capable of many amazing
things but that was something they
probably weren't aware of I am here to
resolve behavior problems major
behavioral problems in dogs usually but
cats and other animals and all my cases
Come to Me by veterinary referral and so
her vet doctor called me and described a
situation with a large number of corgis
fighting one another they just happened
to live in Windsor hmm I wonder if it's
the queen thought I
um so and it's really important that we
have access to the veterinary records of
the patient concerned and and I did in
this occasion and and I was ably
assisted by the vet who referred them in
this instance and she was a frequent
attendee at the local veterinary
practice taking on them taking a pets
there herself just as would you and I so
I repeat this was a Hands-On caring dog
owner the key problem with this pack of
corgis was that they were fighting one
another and so and my first concern was
to
what do you do if there's a dog fight
and I recommended she what I gave her
the equivalent of a miniature carbon
dioxide cylinder and it's called
nowadays commercialized as a Pet
Corrector which is sold across the world
there's one dog in particular called
chipper who seemed to be the ring leader
and the instigator of a lot of fights so
he was re-homed to her daughter Princess
Anne and she's a great great dog lover
in their own right so that was the
frequency and intensity of fights
thereafter decreased but there were more
fights and then numbers gradually
decreased as old age and death took over
the dogs so by 2016 she had no dogs so
she went through a period of some years
with Douglas and then prince Andrew gave
her a couple Corgi puppies and it all
started against it at her deathbed
pleasingly she had the company of her
beloved corgis I think her first little
call Google was called Susan and was
given to her when she was a child and as
so often happens when you're first
exposed to a breed of dog which you love
dearly and you think that's the only
breed of dog that matters she's been
incredibly loyal to this breed she's had
in total I'm told that the order 30 and
it was so lovely that in her last couple
years she had two two little corgis and
and other dogs around her because
there's no doubt that any of us at any
stage in our life but particularly when
our life is if you like declining and
stressful to be able to reach and stroke
and be loved by an uncritical admirer
which is a dog it's a great comfort I'm
quite certain that her husband Prince
Philip took a more critical view of the
Queen's love of dogs yeah he himself
loved animals of course he himself had
commented on the excessive numbers of
corgis and who knows that maybe there's
competition for
time affection space these were dogs
that like so many of us were spoiled
indulged but also treated firmly and
effectively I visited Windsor Park their
home of prince Andrew to see his dogs as
it happened two little terriers and it's
a fantastic environment for dogs so
these dogs will be pampered there is a
again a household a family and and
servants and they will be well careful
just as they'd be accustomed to being
cared for well in Balmoral and and
Windsor and the other places and most of
the time much of their lives have been
spent in Windsor and Prince Andrew's
house is located about two miles from
the castle so for them it will be a
matter of going home if you like my
understanding is that the dogs were a
bar moral in the end of her emergency's
life really it is my certain knowledge
that they traveled wherever possible
always with her majesty so not overseas
trips but you've all seen images of them
climbing the set types of airplanes
trains cars and she herself would drive
the dogs around she told me a story
which I really was in the context of
seeking advice for having 11 dogs
from her house in Buckingham Palace to
about 20 miles away Windsor Castle down
this highway the M4 and
I've got these darn yapping dogs in the
back of the car you can't concentrate
they're so noisy why are they so excited
in the car she would say and and then
mum who else was in the car with you
nobody no she drove herself in this beat
up old truck wearing her patented image
of the headscarf without any security
detail with no one else in the car a
public Highway with 10 or 11 dogs
yapping in the back and so it's just a
fantastic image of her with a break for
freedom freedom from the intrusive press
tv
people like the great public with their
fascination with all things Royal and
all things to do with the queen and her
dog so the queen was so relaxing talking
about her life and times with her dogs
with me and that clearly it was the side
of her life that she so enjoyed I as
also with her horses one particular
anecdote concerned a British politician
who I might name who rather stupidly
said mum how can you tell one dog from
another they all look the same to me so
she rather as acidically
requested well how do you know one of
your children from another in other
words these dogs are my children you
stupid man can't you tell of course
they're different
and put it put him in his place
[Music]
foreign